go live we are
live okay
everybody we are now live welcome
everyone to the October 10
infrastructure meeting
today um there are no
apologies um and we had a public forum
before in
Darren's meeting and the community
well-being um and the issues raised by
Mr West will be discussed in the
activities report later on in this
agenda so we actually have um a plethora
of items today we have LLY housing ltp
assumptions temporary road closures
Council own property land disposal 3
Waters update and the activities report
so first we'll start though with the
minutes of the infrastructure committee
meeting held 5 September can I have
someone uh so the true and correct thank
you Alex move seconded Grant put that
all as in favor I against
car I've been put in here as being an OP
I'm actually on this no it hasn't
been the governance statement has
not there has been no change to that um
the governance statement was updated at
the last meeting I believe there was a
request to put you on but it wasn't in
time for that meeting it was this end of
the September meeting that was done
right okay and that's been updated yes y
okay thank you right now we'll go to the
minutes of the waste Advisory Group held
on the 11th of September now I can put
those V do you want to second that um
all those in favor I I that is carried
Now we move on to elderly persons
housing housing and the policies uh
speaking to that is
ran C floor is yours
um so with me today also have um Hannah
who's done a lot of work on the policy
and hether from the infrastructure team
so we can answer any questions so um
we've been working on this elderly H
person's housing policy essentially to
codify the existing practice um there
has been the tenant information booklet
that you'll also note that's attached to
this report that's been provided to all
of the existing tenants we've also o
undertaken a
pre-engagement um meeting in hooie as
part of the process for developing this
policy that was held age concern a few
weeks ago the mayor was in attendance at
that houie as well um essentially this
policy is intended for the existing
elderly person's housing activity that
Council runs it doesn't relate to any
new um projects that might be run in the
future and it doesn't affect tenants
that are already in the the facility um
it is about um or some some elements
relate the sorry I'm going to start
again those elements where there is a
change will only relate to new tenants
there aren't actually many changes from
current practice but there are a few
areas and that will relate to new
tenants um so I'm happy to take any
questions right I'm going to open up uh
Tom um chair I have three questions um
put them quickly if you wish me to um
the first one is and I'm looking at the
housing policy now and I I note that
included in assets is prepaid funeral
accounts which seem may be pretty
difficult to classify as in asset I
wondered why that was included in there
I mean you can access
it so through you chair yes prepaid
funeral accounts um while they are
basically paid to either Council in
terms of paying off a plot or in terms
of paid to a funeral director they're
basically money's held until you die so
they can still be recovered at any time
so there's still an asset in terms of
that okay second one um I I I noticed
that we are changing the policy so that
someone can move up and down the waiting
list depending on the Circ circumstances
presumably of them but also of other
people coming on to the waiting list to
might move above them so in other words
you you have to satisfy certain criteria
to get in waiting list but once you're
on the waiting list then you can be you
might get to number five on just but you
get bumped in at number 10 or something
because and and two questions I wondered
whether there was fundamental fairness
in that but my second question And
probably this is the main one is is
there more than one person involved in
that decision
um the a decision to move somebody down
the waiting list it would seem to me
would be something where you would
require at least sort of oneup
approval again through you um it would
be unusual for us to change where
someone sits in the waiting list um the
opportunity for the change to the
waiting list would be in the very rare
occasion we would have someone who
urgently required uh accommodation that
we might want to put in at the top in
terms of who makes decision it's a it's
a staff decision and then elevated to
management so it's it's not an
individual person's decision because it
does give a variety of reasons why
somebody can be moved Cas it would be it
would be elevated to management because
it would be a a you know Senior
Management so my my third question um
chair is the under the allocation of
rental unit
paragraph headed allocation Oriental
units it says the application the the
applicant has only two days to decide
whether to accept a unit or not which
seem to me to be you know a bit
difficult if you're an elderly person
and somebody calls you day one you got
to make a decision by day three um I
mean this is probably a view I would
Express rather than a question it just
seems to me to be very very tight timing
and you know why do we not give them 5
days or something or a week or something
that just seems more reasonable me and
and that's a fair comment and we could
amend the policy to reflect a different
time frame if Council just determined
that that to be the case just on that I
think if you are on the waiting list it
means that you are ready to go and if
you you would take yourself off at any
stage so I yeah if if it needs is a
particular house so that's a point you
got offered a particular house okay
right we've got alen and then
M's not so much a question it's a
compliment actually I just think that
I've never seen such a well-written
little booklet as that um ten tenant
information booklet it's just so well
written it's got all the stuff that you
need to know in an easy to understand
format it's the best one of the best
things I've ever seen written to be fair
perfect there we go R um yeah I I
definitely support that I just want to
come back to um where Tom was kind of
going towards changing circumstances and
I've um looked at the the um sentence
says where an existing tenant is no
longer able to live independently
Council will work with the tenant and
the or next toin as appropriate to help
them find more suitable accommodation if
they can't live independently it's
either a medical reason or a capacity
reason right is that where this
is yes that is the case because if
that's the case then they need to either
go into um a an appropriate W time or a
medical W home and they're not available
for at least 20 CL days so what do you
intend to do with a tenant while they're
trying to find where they can go um so
I'm I'll probably pass this back to
Heather um as well but um the point is
you can't just um and there's no desire
to um Force someone out of their
accommodation because the circumstances
change it's usually an evolving
situation and um and as I understand it
and again I'm sure Heather will speak to
this but um this is something that does
arise unfortunately with this particular
group of people um it is managed well
very well at the moment by the housing
team and they're aware of um managing
that process and making it happen um no
no one's going to be forced out quickly
it's a it's a conversation and it's
about facilitating those options um
again as been raised elsewhere in the
report um there is a chronic shortage of
all of that type of accommodation um
again there is no ability um legally
speaking to evi someone from their house
um we wouldn't want to do that either um
so again that doesn't change things but
it it again it's something that that
we're aware of um it's probably a
problem that honestly is only going to
increase with time um so hence hence
flagging it now um I don't if you had
anything else to add to that but
um right
Evelyn uh yes I too would like to
comment on the Excellence of the um
brocher part but I have a couple of
questions one is the fact that we are
expecting people coming in to provide
carpets and
curtains
um given that some people come into or
apply for accommodation because they are
in a particularly needy situation is
that realistic or do they have the
option of taking over previous tenants
um fixtures and fittings I ask this
because it's less common than it used to
be to be asked to provide curtains and
and carpets when go to accommodation
these days so through your chair
generally speaking what happens is the
existing tenant who's moved out would
leave their carpets or drapes um not
carpets cuz carpets are fixed for
covering and they're covered by Council
um drapes or curtains in the unit um if
there is no intention for them to leave
them as such then we would provide some
assistance or help a tenant to find find
a
reasonable material um carpet to oh not
carpet why am I thinking carpet sorry
curtain or dropes to replace um the ones
that are there yeah no thank you for
that because I I felt a little bit
uncomfortable that we might be expecting
people to do something that they might
be a bit challenged to do um the other
thing was the
um in the information that we provide
the tenant and it's sort of a little bit
in line with Council C camel's question
about the amount of time that you have
to make the decision um we're just going
through this process too and it was
recommended to us that we encourage
people to get independent advice and
from age concern and Southern Community
Law and places like that that provide at
no cost um so that people can actually
afford to get the advice um but actually
encourage them to do it because in
actual fact not everybody who is going
to come in is going to
necessarily understand the complexities
of what they're agreeing to um are we
going to follow up that suggestion as
well um and include that in what we
encourage people to do before they sign
a lease with
us uh through your cheer yes we could
add that to the policy um to the
procedure uh it's good advice for them
we generally speaking when they come in
to sign up they have someone with them
um so they could quite easily um take
independent legal advice either from the
Community Law or they could go to age
concern or any of those other
organizations to assist uh we certainly
encourage people to who are signing up
to have someone with them at the time so
we can just put that into the policy say
or the procedure as part of the
process thank you Mr Mayor um just on
section four that there seem to be a bit
of a ban on dogs and I just wonder
whether that's consistent with the South
District Council I think they may be
open to some dogs given that small lap
dogs are quite a bit of company for
older people that are by themselves I
know if you open it up it's a bit of a
slippery slide about what you have ation
on a rot wheeler versus something much
smaller than that but I just wonder
whether that's consistent with what our
neighboring council's got and whether
there's some potential for an aging
person to have a small dog that they
might be quite attached
to so I can confirm that in some
instances the South District Council
does allow dogs are they are quite
specific about the type of dog um and
the age so the dog has to have been with
the family for certain period of time um
prior to developing the policy we've
done quite a bit of extensive research
around whether dogs are appropriate in
our um housing space they there's
there's limited space for them to be
able to exercise their dog off a leash
inside the complexes without disturbing
any other the other tenants um it's
unfair I believe to have a dog inside
all the time so they have to have some
outdoor space um and it's very difficult
for the way units are set up to have a
specific outdoor space for them to do
that
um it's also difficult to manage noise
control for a dog um that might be
disturbing the neighbors as
well I think the district approach is
different to that they don't have U
secluded areas for dogs to run around
them they just expect the tenants to be
able to get out and walk their dogs on a
leave and then bring them
back that's okay I understand this is
not an easy an easy one to
approach I think it's worth worth noting
that this policy is codifying existing
practice existing practice does not
allow dogs of any kind we are correcting
that to allow for disability assistance
dogs which is important just to be clear
that that should be allowed and
obviously we are balancing up all all of
the interests and needs of the tenants
with maintenance requirements um so in
fact this policy as it stands will allow
a greater access for dogs than pre than
is currently the
procedure thank you right okay any
further questions or comments if not
Peter you on the list oh no Sor I'm not
on the list thank you uh I I've had a
quick Lo through the agreements here for
the uh uh elderly housing I can't can't
find anything where the tenants aren't
allowed to operate a small business out
of there is there anything there that
I've
missed what sort of small
business um we haven't had that issue
come up at all during either the
engagement or the policy preparation
stage it's strange CU we had a large
business being operated out of one of
house a few years back well we'll just
leave it at that a few few years ago not
just recently well a few years back time
flies when you're getting
older I'll take that under
advisement right okay so we've got some
uh three recommendations here we
received the report you're right Alex we
note the tenant information booklet and
recommend to council that it adopt the
person's housing policy as it is but we
do are we going to have some alterations
that um when it comes to council at the
end of the month that will be identified
so Bas on the basis of this conversation
my understanding is we're going to
increase the notice period for decisions
from 2 days to 5 days right and nothing
with the dogs stay as
is I think as is is consistent I'm a dog
lover and I know the problems they can
create and I think you've got a eror on
the S of caution sorry except for
disability related service dog yeah
thank you so everyone's happy with
that okay so can I have someone move as
three thanks Pia seconded rare put those
all those in
favor against that is carry thank
you we go now to ltp
assumptions I watched a movie that said
the assumptions were something to do
with the mother or something
but so Randon back again with the
assumptions K counselors um so the risk
and insurance committee has received and
discussed these draft assumptions from a
risk perspective um this report allows
the infrastructure committee to consider
those assumptions that relate
specifically to
infrastructure um so this report focuses
on those elements and um brings some
additional information forward for the
committee to consider I we just note
from the conversation this morning in
the workshop with um Emergency
Management South and just as this report
indicates we are waiting for advice from
environment South as to um proposed
assumptions around managing of
emergency and disaster
situations um so that is something that
we will bring back again to the risk and
Assurance committee um so basically in
this report I've just tried to pull out
the main things that will be of interest
to this committee I am happy to go
through them all just to take questions
whatever is your preference chair no I
think we did that they're quite
comprehend iive and I
imagine that all assumptions are
evidence-based so there is evidence
behind each one so I'm open up um the
committee now for questions comments Mr
may just an observation on some of the
um pre uh some of the facts that are
here so on page uh two of the report on
page 46 of board books uh right down
there at the bottom it says economic
diversification and it lists a few
Industries there that are less likely to
bring significant employment growth I'm
not sure about that uh green hydrogen um
has a potential for 2,000 workers when
the plant's being constructed and about
200 workers once it's operational
certainly estimates that I've seen
around uh the um aquaculture area is
that there's somewhere between 1, and
1500 jobs involved across three salmon
farms and some other um agiculture
Investments uh in Bluff itself around
the old freezing work so not not sure
that that's less than likely I guess is
what I'm
saying and bit further over on the
following page one of the things that
seems to be missing in in the whole list
is that there's no mention of the sale
of property or other assets that we have
in our headwind so we've
got 16 Properties or plots to be
disposed of and we've got a a recent
list of I'm not sure how many it was but
but um it's in one of these reports
about the disposal of some Council owned
options later on the agenda which again
are quite significant value-wise
$40 $50 million worth
potentially ran do you think I don't
personally I don't think they would be
applied as an assumption that's
something that happens um and why these
assumptions are here I can see you need
that background for the LT P
um yeah that's my view you want to
comment on
that
um I think that's correct chair in terms
of the sale of any particular assets
would be something that would flow
through into the budget forecasting
itself rather than as an assumption as
such um the finance and projects
committee will receive a similar paper
on the financial assumptions and that's
where such a matter might be dealt with
but it wouldn't come through as an
assumption it would come through as a
budget matter Grant yeah just page four
microphone please microphone oh sorry um
page four or five of the report round
asset life and conditions
um we had a discussion a while back
about how we make really informed
decisions around that and and using data
and Technology to be able to make really
informed decision as opposed to just
depreciation or approach have we is
there any progress on that or where are
we on the infrastructure assets yeah
would you like to comment on that thank
you yes happy happy to speak to that and
Russell may wish to pipe in as well um
look a agree you can make more
appropriate decisions and I guess sweat
your assets further if you've got more
information about them as opposed to
just um working on an average ass life
we are making steps to improve our asset
data so for example our Wastewater
Network we've now got quite a
significant um process for CCTV those
lines so we can actually get condition
assessments of how they're going um as
they approach that end of life and make
decisions around whether or not we can
extend the asset life um unfortunately
it's not as easy with water pipes that
are are under pressure
um but honestly it's one of those things
where we're wanting to continue to keep
up with technology and improve our asset
data and asset management um but that
also comes with some costs associated
with that front end piece as well and
Russell and I have worked on putting
some additional budget into the
long-term plan around how we use that
technology and Analysis better to be
able to look at those asset lives and
push those as hard as we can rather than
just using the generic um asset life
Russell did you have anything to add
thanks Mr chair every three years we
revalue our assets and during that time
we have an independent um value assess
both the quantum and things like the
asset lives against national standards
so I guess that's another opportunity
that we take to actually assess so any
of our assets that tend will be at the
end of the life we we add extra asset
life on so we may have assets that are
actually longer than than than the
standard default age anyway so we
continue to monitor that and look to
extend them as far as that is sensible
and reasonable that we can convince both
our independent um peer reviewer and
audit yeah cuz I know in crosss for
example through AWS they monitoring how
the infrastructure responds to small
Quakes live and so they can understand
what's happening on those different bits
of infrastructure and you know there's a
technology solution to this and it's not
just an inago City issue it's a whole
infrastructure New Zealand local
authority issue but I think that that
pip inspection as Erin mentioned is very
good and and what Russell is saying
about we're not sweating our assets but
we're being sensible about about their
life so you're comfortable we're getting
as accurate information possible barrier
assets um I I think that there's you
know technology is evolving and we can
we can always be better and as an
industry um honestly we're we're not as
an industry where we would like to be in
terms of best for asset all the time um
what I would say though is because of
the continued investment that in vagle
city has made in renewing its assets at
a reasonable time I think a lot of um
councils are probably leaning more into
technology than we have because they are
looking to have to make some pretty
tough decisions around pushing their
assets quite quite hard simply because
they don't have the money to invest in
them um we don't have as big a backlog
of infrastructure deficit which means
that we are you know we we aren't
pushing our assets as hard as some other
areas are and therefore we're not
investing as hard in that technology but
it's something that we need to get the
balance right to make sure that we're
not investing in assets too
early thanks uh for the questions
Tom chair I mean I think these are
excellent Central estimates let's call
it that way for
assumptions um but some of them have
quite a large range associated with them
and the question arises how we plan for
the sort of you know range of possible
outcomes rather than just a single point
outcome so that's a question for staff
um I mean if if if you look at something
like um you know clim CL change comes to
mind and the possible range of
temperature outcomes from you know half
a degree to 3° well pretty big
difference um maybe that's one of the
most obvious but you got to wait 70
years to get to that point but there are
anyway there's a number of areas where
there's a range and I just wonder
whether we actually are planning with
intention of recognizing the fact that
um we don't actually know the outcome
you know we're just choosing a central
estimate and alone for the fact that
there's a range of possible outcomes
do you want to talk about that
Quantum yes so I think again it's it's
similar to the question um to rather the
response that Erin provided to the last
question that you've got to balance up
the investment that you make in your
assumptions and your scenario planning
against the benefit in terms of the
outcome um we're taking the medium
median range for example on climate
change and as best as possible designing
um our for example our storm water pip
types for that increased scenario each
ltp cycle gives an opportunity to review
um and there may be certain aspects that
next ltp round for example we would look
at particular scenarios and invest more
this ltp round the focus has been on the
scenarios around three Waters and what
will happen in terms of retaining three
Waters or not retaining three Waters um
and so that by necessity in the
infrastructure space has been an area of
focus um but certainly more range of
scenarios could be something looked at
for future
ltps thank you Ranna right we've got
some uh two recommendations we received
the report and uh note and provide
feedback on the items relevant to
infrastructure included in the draft
assumptions for the ltp you I have
someone move that please uh moved Evelyn
seconded Leslie I'm going to put that
all those in favor I against that is
carried thank you that moves on now to
Temporary road closures and Russell
you're already
seated thanks Mr chair this is part of
our normal process I guess this time of
year for the tour of Southland the tour
of Southland obviously is a um one of
our Premier Events for Southland and
this requires us to um stop temporarily
stop some of the roads around Queens
Park on on two days that everybody's
generally aware of in Southland it's
it's typically well controlled and um
well managed and seems to operate Reas
me seamlessly um so I'm happy to receive
questions right questions anyone pretty
straightforward move the recommendation
thank you moved and seconded I'll put
that all those in favor I against that
is carried that is sorry that is all
three recommendations
there great okay that moves on now to
our disposal of infrastructural
land right who is speaking to this
hether and I are but he's disappeared
somewhere we'll just find her right
we'll wait till
he paging
hether
yeah that's your no Russell it's all
yours right welcome
Heather do you want to talk us uh
introduce the the method behind the
madness so this is a follow on from the
workshop in terms of land disposal that
um was carried out earlier this year and
you've already received some land
disposal proposals from
through Parks and Recreation through
the um for a previous report this land
is specifically mostly infrastructure
land um and um the report details some
parcels of land that staff have
identified as being suitable for either
repurpose or
disposal um and what staff determined
their strategic value for them to be and
um whether they lines with uh council's
Strate strategic
assessment um is yet to be
determined Russell has some further
information that might be of assistance
in that regard specifically in relation
to the car parking
spaces so what we really were trying to
do is try to align how strongly they
they are strategically to and how needed
they are in the future and I guess
that's the that's the key St starting
point that we were suggesting is for our
infrastructure land is do we need it for
the future and and how does it align so
rather than um seek disposal earlier
than in 5 years time we come back and
need need a piece of land so what we've
tried to prepare is the paper and and
and rank some of those um in terms of
some of the car Parks we've we've
highlighted um a range of those um I
guess Open Spaces that have that have
opportunities and sometimes the
opportunity for car parking might not be
the Strategic purpose going forward so I
guess that's what we've tried to
incorporate into that table and we're
happy to receive some questions on it
just just one question before I go to
Darren is that we were hoping to get uh
Revenue back on those say the 131s
street um that you know the return we
are actually are getting from car
parking do we have
that uh yes we have crunched some
numbers yep just to give the the
committee so revenue from 131 Street is
estimated
78,000 per perom 78 wow yeah less
10% yeah just under 10% Revenue uh
return and for 116 s 30 Deon Street uh
26,000 which is a 2.9% return right and
for 111 street it's um
216,000 which is a 3.3%
return okay thanks right Darren sorry
question thanks I guess my my questions
are around the car parking spaces and
whether or not they're not being used if
they're not being used um then then
maybe there's an issue but liven Street
for example I inquired about getting a
space there last year and was told there
was a several months um waiting waiting
list it might be that if the return on
Liv street is if it's at 3% then maybe
it's a good jog to to look at
um parking the rates um but if if the
car Parks aren't empty I'm I can't say
that I'm tremendously supportive of not
having them there we almost lost 131s a
couple of years ago because I think um
Ministry of Justice were looking at
relocating the courts there um but it's
just those people who are looking for
paid permanent parking or semi-permanent
parking close to town they
AR as many options bearing in mind that
there are 700 car parks that have just
opened up in bako Central um that's not
everybody's cup of tea either right
thanks uh Trish just like to draw your
attention which I'm sure you know is
that the Ministry of Education is moving
into space Street and they have um they
have 12 cars that they they with them um
work cars which have probably got that
I'm not sure but there's probably 45 to
50 staff um will be based in the year so
they'll need
car just something you might like to
think
Tom I mean I don't suppose we're going
to work through them one at a time but
I'm all just comment that to me 131s
street is the perfect location for in
Town
Apartments um and I I don't think that
we it would make any sense our all to be
getting ready of that for
790,000 yeah so you actually prompted me
there Tom so what what we'll do is we
we'll actually weed some out so we can
actually talk about there's a couple of
ones so 1111 Street the uh the one by
the library I think um does anyone agree
that we should keep that retain that yes
um unless anyone wants to okay so we'll
just note that then we'll go to 131 s
Street I think we've just talked about
that very
strategic uh for either development or
retaining so Mr Sher can I be recorded
as not commenting
on because of their potential conflict
of interest can I just ask Mr chair
about 116s Street and just how how used
is 116 s Street 30 de
Street I know about the differ street
but I'm just not sure about the one one
sucess street but so that's that site is
guess the building that's next to the um
Scottish Hall and it extends around into
Deon Street and the Scottish Hall the
the building um could looked to be
demolished but we haven't we never
demolished it so that could certainly be
a site that could be disposed of and the
car parking in 30 de street is well
utilized as um we work pretty hard to
create leases on them all to get as much
revenue as we can yes you can see 30
different street as well used but 116
street looks to me like it's a vacant
building that's correct does have some
materials that we've stored in it but it
but we can't store too many vehicles
because of the some of our building
regulations thank you sorry Darren was
it you next yeah thanks to you I'm I'm
not hugely opposed to the disposal of 1
through One S Street but I would flag
the potential issue around tenants on
those sites is a res reverse sensitivity
one because
there are uh light Industries on the
other side of the road and they were
there
first rather than somebody having their
daytime snooze interrupted by a panel
bet so so with the uh debron Street E
Street one is that is that are they two
separate titles or is that all one they
currently H is um Mr chair is one title
right but but potentially they could be
separated but at the moment they are one
title so the building
could be sold and the the back car park
would need a subdivision to occur and it
would create some cost okay Lizzie can I
just point out that site particularly
the 116s street could also be said to be
an ideal apartment
area under what Tom was talking about
yes yeah yeah okay uh look I'm going to
next Peter and then I'm going to uh
thank you Mr chair I've already got my
answer Mr PE okay so I'm going to I'm
going to just group uh 131s and the
Deon 16x s together that we I actually
move that we actually hold on to them at
the moment for the various reasons uh
people talked about either car parking
or
housing sorry just got a really question
Sor um I've just want to um ask for some
clarification so the property 131 E
Street um I understand that if it's
classified then it's a first refusal to
naho because it was taken under the
Public Works
act correct and we we're permitted to
use it for car parking purposes for any
other purposes we are obliged to um
negotiate with M right yes I think the
status quo is working Alex I've just got
a clarification there chair you said um
131 and one one sex to be retained for
potential future purposes including
housing you po
potentially are you meaning us to put
housing there oh no no I I think that
Tom you mean that I think you didn't
mean us doing it but the ability it
could be uh developer maybe want to do
that preference I think in my mind was
the elderly housing elderly housing I
mean if you if you take the case of the
fact that you know that nah is so
doesn't make any difference who does it
actually yeah you know building building
apartments in the city would be I think
a very welcome thing yeah you is that
okay I agree um just to extend to that
so why would we not dispose of it so for
that purpose
then but we haven't we we I guess um
Heather we can't if we dispose of it we
can't say is for that purpose we know
that but as I'm I guess what I'm
cautioning us or maybe not cautioning us
but querying sorry is that if we decide
now not to dispose of it for potentially
those reasons the can't come up again
for another six months because then we'd
be relating a decision we've already
made not to dispose this piece of land
so if we had a developer come hey yay
you were talking about potentially
putting housing there and that looks
like what you'd be excited about doing
we can't make that decision again are we
locked in for six
months we I mean we can actually put the
decision on hold we can actually don't
we don't actually have to we can
withdraw those is that right yeah so um
Mr cheer in terms of the six months so
there is a Prohibition on Rel litigating
once a motion has been made unless there
is a notice of motion signed by I think
75% of counselors to um reconsider that
decision so it is possible to um to
change that decision in the event that
it is a developer com comes along but
it's not good practice that is not good
practice so I guess so I'm just
highlighting that whatever yeah whatever
decision we make now we can't rewrite
out of it in 6 months time without 75%
of us all signing on the do line you
still have to go to yeah so so before I
go to the mayor I'm going to ask you I
was more for 116 rather than
131 thank you chair um I'd just like to
clarify I think along the lines of um
councelor Campbell's point which is just
that that was the piece of land where if
we were able to get central government
funding to Fast Track building elderly
housing which would be done by Council
that was the piece of land that we
identified as being the quickest um path
to be able to move forward with a
development and essentially be shovel
ready um as quickly as possible so from
that housing perspective if we were
looking to you we' we've discussed you
know that potential of whether we wanted
to build significantly more elderly
housing that would be a key piece of
land at the moment just in terms of our
ability to do that quickly any there are
a number of other pieces of land
available but because they have reserved
status they would take longer to make
shovel
ready right so that this decision to not
put it on the market right now wouldn't
prohibit that not at all no no not one
no okay you happy Alex or you still I
would I think in that case would your
chair be more comfor taking them
separately yeah I'll take them
separately so we'll go for 131 first
everyone's happy to retain that for the
various reasons oh sorry Mr just wanted
to clarify the uh incumbents that's on
the title so it says there the uh that
we have a right to use it for a car park
if we decided to use it for housing we
Council decid to use a housing uh what's
the position with the N who Claims
Settlement so
please correct me if I'm incorrect but
it would essentially we would require
nahu approval to change the status
that's correct Heather um and on the
basis that a number of our discussions
have been had around progressing elderly
housing um potentially in partnership
with
nahu um we wouldn't expect that to be a
likely hindrance to that
work thank you okay so one through one
up for discussion you just um show fans
you're all okay not to sell out cool
radio and noting my it's noted yep
you're noted and so
11630 um Keen to keep that as well
yeah yes for the moment for the moment
yeah I mean six months is quite a short
time um in this world
okay that moves us on to
some couple of big ones and that is 313
Bay
Road we I think we did Le Street we're
keeping the library car park so here the
the big hun of
grass so that's literally what it is
it's a rural piece of land which is
being leased um can be sold with the
Perpetual lease in place or the um the
lease may make an offer to purchase if
we wish to do so okay so so it is
returning us how much again was it
returning a very low income on that
um it it's only got a the income on that
is only
2750 right a land and it's a 21e lease
so the rental would have been quite some
time ago got ay
here sorry Evelyn sorry everyone quiet
um just a question regarding whether
this piece of land has any relevance to
our climate change resilience going
forward given that
um where actually is located as one of
the principal flood zones
so if we look at where what its
potential future is as a as a farm may
not be that great U which is why we're
not getting a high return off it at the
moment I I presume um is this a piece of
land that Council itself could put to
use in terms
of
um future proofing some of our
infrastructure nearer to the city and I
ask this genuinely because I don't know
the answer but I suspect that some
people have looked at it Darren so from
a district plan perspective no because
of the fact that it's in an inundation
Zone
um and it's in a rural Zone yes so that
would sit on the limb if if if you were
looking to exit it um really it's it's
appropriate for Rural activity not much
else you wouldn't create a subdivision
on it and uh anybody who was entering
into it would know that if there's a if
there's a big rainfall there's a good
chance that you'll have a great
Pond and hence my question
weac if we were inclined I'm not sure
what we would put on
it no so any other comments about this
because I'm going to put this one
up I think I I understand what Evelyn's
meaning in terms of look the um the land
was originally ear marched by the
infrastructure team to do landbased
drainage of the area um we've it's one
that we've been chewing around for a
little while going actually do we think
that um it is the piece of land to do
that on um and what we've decided is
that no we we don't believe that is the
right piece of land for us to hold for
that
purpose right can I um Peter yeah all I
want to know please uh what's the hect
hect 23 hect 23 thank you okay so I'm
going to ask for someone to move that we
sell it I was going to ask a question
yeah ask a question what's about the
previous one about the par car park why
did we decide not we're not selling
that which
car
street I think everyone realized that it
was a good asset to have and it returned
so what's the return on
2.9% there was a comment that uh Council
low made that it may need to be
increased that but that's that's a
separate that was on E is this 11 Street
3.3 3.3% yeah so it's under the cost of
capital and we're going to hold
it yes we need car
packing and it's so um just to satisfy
return When do we make um when do we
revise U parking charges every year
every year so that can
happen question as part of our fees and
charges what a parking what a parking
cost need to rise to to make a capital
return on it because we're making 7 or
8% down here yeah that's well that's if
that valuation of the site is correct
so Russ so Mr CH what we've done there
is we've estimated the value of the car
park based on the value of the site
because the way the valuation record is
held holds both the car park and the
library in one title so we could come
back with a revisit of what the
valuation of the car park building alone
would be what we do know over the over
the last few years is that the um yes
the public usage of the the car park
decreased quite rapidly so we've um gone
the opposite way and we have the
building about 75% least now um as a
facility and to be fair we've continued
to we've only got two decks where we
have Public Access there anyway and it's
quite po possible we should revisit to
one to increase the return on that
carpack so it is um It is Well utilized
um and as Council l pointed out we've we
have I guess a varying um waiting list
at times for that and it is one of the
um I guess better access points
undercover parking right close to your
CBD is actually quite an advantage so um
I think we we just might need to revisit
the valuation which I think could impact
the rate of
return right yeah okay
so 313 Bay Road um uh we happy to put
that on the market someone like to move
that Ria second to Tom okay so that's
good we take that one off keep that
takes us to the big one in Bond Street
for one I think there's a bit of history
or story with
this yes Mr Cher this was the original
um Works development yard and um has
been in Council for for a period of time
um when Bond contracts moved out it's
been vacant for a period of time one of
the things that are probably a little
bit I guess while we've moved it to a
medium priority is that it is one of the
vacant pieces of land in that area and
walkar here have now indicated that
councils can own um passenger transport
infrastructure so they can own us a yard
and actually install their own
infrastructure for um EV type technology
so in the past councils weren't allowed
to own that but the some of their more
recent changes so that would be one of
the last larger pieces of land um if
when we go to um to market for a
passenger Transport service provider it
could be a could be a strategic
advantage that you actually use that for
other purposes you could actually own
yourself a Depot is what I'm saying um
but it's something that you may wish to
consider as part of the longer term
process that's why it's moved from I
guess low priority for no other purpose
of council to a medium priority okay
okay so you potentially could be
advising us that strategically and may
be worth holding on to is that right it
sounds that is one of the only larger
pieces of land close in um at this stage
I it's unknown whether that would be in
council's best interest until you
actually had a conversation with the PT
industry okay as far as a purchaser
looking to buy the land and build and
develop it are there restrictions with
its uh hazardous um what underneath
yeah Mr chair I believe um most of bar
Street and most of Mery Street um have
some form of land contamination on them
anyway um they all have different
foundations so I don't think that piece
of land is any different from any other
any of the other areas where buildings
have been built
recently okay uh Tom J I was going to
say that I it doesn't seem to me to be
sensible to hold on to if there is
another p if there's perhaps a purchaser
who establish a business there create
jobs you know and so forth so um I I
think hold not in the off chance given
it's you know a good site it's big site
I don't think makes sense so I
personally would favor marketing it okay
um any other comments questions anyone
okay we'll test the order on uh 141 Bond
Street allows favor of disposing it can
you put your hand
up yeah that's uh that's a yes okay it's
a it's a release on
141 and takes us to the last one which
oh no we've still got I'll go back to
116 es and 30 devron so that's be land
plus an old building that's earthquake
prone building is that
right
oh we've done that I just didn't
see oh drops down one sorry
sorry now we are doing 48 glary Cris
48 seems a strange piece of land that we
don't have a lot of use for there's a
sub station on
it okay so it's um speed through this uh
anyone Keen to
dispose yeah that okay um shove hands
for to dispose of 48 lary yeah okay
that's our release as
well and we we do sorry CH we we do need
to know whether pernet can actually move
that equipment um and where they would
move it to because it presumably
Services the houses around about
it Mr we've had several conversations
with pet over the last decade about um
whether the opportunity ities as the
networks upgraded whether we could
release that land and actually turn it
into a sellable site but at this stage
we haven't been able to find an economic
solution where they would move their
their equipment they may well wish to um
take ownership and um contribute
significantly to to us
perhaps the site's only got a
Transformer on it and it's a gravel site
and it's um it's an unusual piece of
land that we've somehow created over a
long period of time so was owned by if
someone bought it would it be
detrimental to
pet a new owner no it's got easements on
it for accessing to and from so right
typically it' be quite difficult to
build anything on the site so um it'll
be an interesting s sale okay whom would
be interested right so that we've got
that all done now um the
recommendations
right just pay
rent right put the one two three no
recommendations there um move that rear
seconded who's going to second that uh
Grant Okay so we've got the whole uh six
of
those statements there uh all those in
favor I against carried thank you for
that um takes us to three Waters reform
program update
um I'll be covering that one
yeah okay nothing's happening so we'll
move on to
[Laughter]
next um sorry Andrew wasn't available
today so I'll be covering that one um
look as uh councelor pottinger has
alluded to we are in a bit of a holding
period at the moment on water reform
pending the outcome of the election um
probably the the key piece of that i'
just draw your attention to is um should
labors plan to proceed um with the with
the 10 entity model go ahead um we have
been provided our draft um date to
transition towards the new entity and
that's currently proposed to be 1
October
2025 um that is a a date that probably
hasn't um won a lot of support from from
um the atago and Southland councils um
as you'll be aware most of the other
atago Southland councils had supported
in a date of 1 July 2025 um to coincide
with the end of the financial year um
they weren't very happy with a with an
October date and in particular concerns
around that overlapping with the local
body elections and the the fact that
that is already quite a busy time um
were were not favored um by Chief EX
tives um around atago Southland um so
that's been fed back into the entity and
we'll await the outcome of the election
and uh whether or not um there's any
change in that
space right are there any questions
otherwise I'll move that'll be received
the report any questions I'll second you
second it okay put the motion all those
in
favor yes that's car takes us to the
activities report um
I'll just jump in Russell if you got a a
brief minute to come and talk to us
about I spoke to Russell earlier about
Vic West's um um traffic Crossing signal
stuff
and Russell's going to give us a bit of
a history and what we can do thanks Mr
chair without um hearing what Vic had
said um certainly we have two
intersections being sandre Street quen
Drive and uh
Gara Street Queen Drive where we've got
two different controllers for The
Pedestrian phase they were I guess
oneoff type um installations that were
to a certain degree tried but have
remained there as the controllers so
it's a situation where you can hold the
button and it what it does is extends
The Pedestrian phase and I guess that
was Tri a little bit to see whether
there was some T uptake here in inago or
across the country um because the units
that are built were customized the the
difficulty we have is that they do have
the external speakers and I guess it's
depending on the voice quality and I
wasn't aware that the voice quality had
was degrading but I can certainly go and
try it and actually if it has degraded
we could look at upgrading some of those
units um to my understanding the the
main um I guess controller piece for it
still is quite operational so I should
be we should should be able to improve
it so you you were saying to me before
that the uptake as hasn't been around
the country as strong no I don't know of
anywhere else I'm not aware of anywhere
else across the country where it's been
um that Technology's been installed was
it contemplated at all for a in a
city um typically what's said across the
country is you have a standard
pedestrian I guess travel speed that you
you allow for and that was really
because of some of our wide streets
particularly in that location going to
the park it was really trial to see
whether or not we could come up with
something cleverer um but it needed some
other um I guess customized pieces and
that hasn't been the piece that has gone
very well across the rest of the country
okay
Darren it's immediately adjacent one of
them is immediately adjacent and the
other's not far away from blind citizens
rooms that they leas from us at Queens
Park so I'm guessing that that they've
placed a value on it and I'm encouraged
to hear that you know Russell can have a
look and see if there's some equipment
we can replace and and upgrade with what
I'm more concerned about is there was a
request for service lodged and it
vanished did can you remember how long
ago Vic lodged Vic said he's lodged
several over a couple of years when he
was in the public forum this afternoon
yeah I can't quantify that he says that
um um but
I Mr chair it could well be that he said
that they're not working very well but
the people have the buttons work fine
but perhaps they've accepted the audio
was working so I'll can go and check
that out um the technology just needs to
be it's yes it's in a quite a vulnerable
place with the weather so it is actually
a little bit it's one of those setups
that uh that we struggle to I might take
the opportunity to come down with you
and have a look and listen you will
respond to help stop you can listen I
can certainly I can certainly go back to
Mr West as well yeah no no that's
excellent right uh the rest of the
activity report anyone want to speak to
it or uh probably two pieces I'd just
draw attention to is the um waste net
approving the or endorsing the stuff uh
approval of the transfer of the regional
Waste Services contract from Bond
Contracting to wasteco um so you'll
start to see some coms out about the
place around um that change and um
overtime differently branded Vehicles
starting to complete that collection uh
the other piece was in relation to the
weather event that we had um from a an
infrastructure perspective in addition
to the high call volume that we were
having uh we also took the opportunity
to stand up our incident Response Team
here at IC um so that response team
operated out of the second floor of the
building and fed into the emergency
Operation Center that was managed by um
uh that was managed out of environment
Southland it was one where I think
there's a number of people in the
building who have had um quite a bit of
experience at doing this but it was a
first time for a number of people as
well so it was a really nice opportunity
to have a little bit of an event that
wasn't too serious and give people a
little bit of a opportunity to step into
that space see what happens um also test
our Network and there there were a few
where we saw Network constraints um and
to Grant's point where that information
then feeds back into us and we we have a
look around what we can do to try to
remove those constraints going forward
in terms of the uh people complaining
about the accumulation of debris on on
drains it's something that we're very
aware of when we go into weather events
particularly at that time of year and
the maintenance team is making an effort
to try to keep those those drains clear
but as you can imagine once you've you
get the rain moving um you're playing
definitely playing a game of of catchup
then trying to keep them them clear and
they aren't always as clear as we'd like
uh the other piece I'd like to note is
just it was probably one of the first
events where we've had a decent test of
our rain Gardens in esen Dawn um and was
really pleased to see that area
performing performing really well um so
I sort of went up there to check it out
going please you know please don't let
there uh be any water ponded around the
place but everything was was coping
really well which was excellent to see
okay
Grant yeah thanks um well just firstly
on that um and thanks for following that
question up from earlier here for me
it's about us being really Ed all
because climate change is going to check
you know number of events like you know
that event particularly was strong wind
then rain and there'll be different
events you know but the more data We
Gather on okay we get this event how
does our infrastructure respond I think
we got to be really agile around that
information and that enables us to best
cope and feeds into how we do things so
that's good to hear we're doing it um in
terms of the report great to see some
action down at Bluff so thank you for
that I know that Community really values
that investment um so thank you for that
in terms of the roading
contract um and this was a question I
raised a few months ago how are we going
to monitor and how will we see the
performance against that contract during
it was a very significant contract we
awarded and I think certainly myself but
there was a few others in the room that
wanted to see regular updates on how's
that contract performing yeah um so in
terms of the transition I'm sorry I'm
just having a a look here I missed that
there was to be a newsletter that was
prepared um by the team around the
transition of the new contract that was
to be attached to the activities report
but it seems to have um fallen off but
we'll make sure we get that distributed
after the meeting um because the key
thing that that's speaking about I guess
is reinforcing um hopefully reinforcing
for you that we've been pushing those
priorities of council really strongly
with the team um and really you know
again around that how we be smarter how
we be more agile how we make sure that
we look like a city that takes pride
inself and that we're spending money in
the right places and particularly how do
we Leverage um as Fon Hogan is our
maintenance contractor how do we
Leverage The Smarts that that
organization has right around the
country um rather than just what people
are perhaps used to seeing in in
Southland um so that's a a message that
I think is getting through loud and
clear to them um what you know it it's
always going to be a work in in progress
we're we're very clear as a team that we
want to we've got a a reasonable
foundation and we want to continue to
get better and better and be you know
one of the top performing networks in
the country um so that's a challenge
that everybody seems to be up for what I
guess I take heart from is that um Bon
Sanderson the head of asset management
and Engineering Services for Fulton
Hogan so essentially the uh manager of
the brains trust I guess that work
within Fulton Hogan on how to do things
smart um it has been allocated onto the
governance group for this contract um I
think that that's a really key step for
them in terms of having their their
really senior people from around the
country involved in our contract and
already starting to see them asking
questions of their own team around have
you thought about doing it this way um
are we working with that team pushing us
to to do things differently than what we
have done in the past so just second
followup so so do we have a performance
contract that is being monitored by both
parties and when would we see that
through this committee if there is one
uh so we we have a contract and we've
got kpis for that contract in place we
haven't bought the individual kpis for
any of our maintenance contracts to
council so I guess if that's something
that elected members are interested in
um we wouldn't want to do it for one
contract it would be something we'd be
wanting to do for I guess perhaps not
all of our contracts but all of our
major contracts um something we'd want
to discuss with Michael when he's back
on Deck yeah You' be good to see
something like that but because that's a
very big contract we do obviously have
our kpis that feed into the quarterly
report um but those aren't contract
specific okay and then just one more not
relating to that um in terms of the
report around potholes so um someone
mentioned earlier the tour of Southland
so if you go down to
um I think it's Deon Street and Galla
Street there's a number of potholes
along there which would cause damage for
bike roders are G 70 km an hour so we
got a plan in place to get that road
sorted out before the race starts or
what are we doing straight to Russell
about
[Laughter]
that I'll come
to so Mr CH we would go around with the
um contract in the tour sou and people
and actually have a look at our sites
and make sure that all of our sites um
and that includes Bluff Bluff Hill and
those sorts of places because each of
those sites are quite variable so
recogniz de on Street sorry Galla Street
has some pavement deterioration that
we're holding off because of water mains
and stuff so it's trying to find the
balance of those things but so that
inspection sufficient time to get the
work done yet there's always a bit of
pressure we also just before the tour go
and sweep those sites so that uh any um
I guess loose material on the roads
removed to avoid damage to B Tires and
in the second intersection the Queen's
draw of tast stre intersection seems to
be really rough and deteriorating quite
quickly there's a number of inations
there and potholes emerging and it's a
very important arterial route as you
understand and it's a state it is and
I'm happy to bring it to their attention
for
you right just while on the subject of
potholes
um and this is this brings in the
contractor because I driving back from
Sandy Point down Bay Road for 3 weeks
consecutively um and the potholes were
still there and I'm thinking well they
got to be fixed you know they it's just
going to happen but um I got to a point
where I was rang Russell and said
Russell um what I do about these
potholes cuz they're not getting fixed
and they were they were um falling the
hole type potholes now you explained to
me Russell that the that this contractor
should be you know inspect ing these
roads and traveling them and obviously
these should be either preventative or
immediately fixed so what's the story
there so sorry chair I've Just Seen Matt
Matt ke I know Matt spoke this morning
but I don't think I've actually formally
introduced Matt to the elected members
so Matt is currently in our
infrastructure operations manager role
and so he has the uh the great job of
being responsible for all of our
operational maintenance contract
including the roing contract pole we
found the we're
have so and the great the great thing
was the great thing was uh those
potholes were immediately fixed after
Russ after Russell was aware of them
admittedly Matt Matt is only in his
initial gearing up phase at Council so
it's probably not the font of knowledge
yet that Russell is but we'll get him
there so I guess my question what went
wrong because I rang Russell Russell
said yes I'm on to it straight away and
it got fixed but our roading contractor
this shouldn't have been a problem so
who would like to talk to that Matt will
you want to jump in
welcome the deep
in uh three South Mr chair um afternoon
evening
Council from an operational perspective
a pothole on the road obviously rfp's
phon through contractor is mobilized to
inspect the site and determine severity
of the pothole that would be then
controlled by way of some temporary
traffic management and an assessment be
made for when that is programmed for a
repair and there's a number of moving
parts to be used to make that call um
you know Workforce and crews out on the
network in that time um location weather
conditions we can't repair potholes when
it is wheet or it's below
10° um due to AC ceiling so um there's a
few things we need to factor in so so
the Bay Road location uh had two weeks
of very poor weather prior to that
reinstatement it was actually a Dugout
that was done to repeate location okay I
I guess my my question is purely not
around the response time it's more
identifying these obvious craters that
that even find whether they've been
there for is our contractor supposed to
be or do we have to wait on public
finding us in a bit of both to be fair
so we've got CYCC Crews that are in
operation across our network but they
can't see every pothole that comes to
fruition so we also rely on the public
to find through
so the the team goes out there and
regularly monitors teral roads but what
I'd encourage everybody if you see
something you think's wrong ring us
because that's obviously the first and
foremost and I guess people ring either
mat or myself or here and and say
there's a pothole we can easy get on on
to that but council poer is right that
our contractors um do need to and we do
have regular routines where they will
drive the major roads and we typically
risk based Stelling on the busy roads
and working our way down so um it's it's
less usual that we would find um them on
the busy roads but they are the roads
that break up often very quickly when
especially when it's been wet so
sometimes you can be there one day and
the next day it's a small something
small got a bit larger so that's why we
need to know what's going on but um we
want everybody who is part of our team
including our internal staff and our
contractors to be our eyes and ears and
that's what uh Matt's saying is that we
although that we can't be everywhere all
the time we want to be able to see
everything as much as we can so it is a
bit of bit of both but so this gets back
to our previous item on assumptions we
don't assume that it's going to be fixed
there we go so found it through any any
other comments questions
Evelyn uh yes Mr ch um just a couple of
things
about the um FL
event um or the things around it so the
leaf thing I've had somebody in my ear
loudly at the last two meetings I've
been with her about aony Avenue David
Street here and the leaf fall there so
it's not so much just the cleaning of
the
um debris which is important but it's
the fact that it seems to have been
reported but nothing has been done about
the trees that are you know so it's a
twofold thing council is involved on
both sides of it there are trees there
that are heavy offenders shall we say um
is one side of our organization able to
speak to the other side of our
organization and get something done
about about that because it seems to be
the um eucalyp type trees and the debris
that comes off those that is in the mind
of this person cuz I don't know I
don't drive anywhere um but it seems to
be causing the problem what can we do
about it because it seems to be
persistent and it seems to be not being
resolved um I might start with that one
and then I'm sure Russell will have
something to add um it's always a
balancing act and you know I'm aware
from my experience here as well as my
experience at other councils that what
is easiest to maintain from an
infrastructure perspective is not always
what is the prettiest for a city um so
as much as you know we we've got areas
where we've got some great historic
trees that are the absolute bane of the
existence of my three Waters team
because those trees are constantly
invading the three Waters Network
causing us blockages um breaking up our
pipes however um I don't think Council
would be looking for us to take some of
those historic Treat Street trees out of
the network um and similarly I know um
how much Russell loves the Cabbage trees
that we have around the network from the
point of view of having to to keep those
clear out of the curban channel um so we
there's regular conversations that are
going on between both teams to try to
get the balance right um but absolutely
we always have trees causing us some
degree of debris when it becomes
excessive I guess Russell may add to
this we we start putting additional
pressure on the parks team around
whether they are I guess assets that we
are really wetted to
keeping and Mr chair guess the like a
flood event team or Mets team in fact
arranged for the contractors to go out
there and inspect all the flood gates
that go out to the through the stock
Banks and that's excuse me the primary
the primary event that we actually
prepare for um what we do know is that
if it blows really hard and then it
rains we know where all the rubbish
that's come from the trees are because
it's washed into the curban channel and
washed over the sump so we know exactly
where it is we just got to go and get it
it's our problem um and I guess that's
the challenge that we face um like most
cities that are fortunate to have a
number of trees that we have an ongoing
issue of just having to go and pick up
the stuff out of there um we do need to
just keep a register of where those
trees are and if they become a nuisance
then um depending on what they are we
just need to um keep them at an
appropriate size if they pine trees like
in algen Street which I think they are
down David Street then we just need to
determine whether they are appropriate
to be there and and we work closely with
our Parks team and we do talk to them um
regularly about um what can stay and
what can't stay um and for the for the
purpose of trying to manage our
infrastructure so we don't destroy
things or it is actually fit for purpose
everybody will have seen Queen's Drive
the day after we've swept it and it's
blown and every leaf in Queens Park is
sitting on Queens Drive um it's
frustrating for the team but it's just a
reality of having the luxury of trees in
their city so and the followup is that
after having moaned I now want to say
something um which I have said to Erin
but I need to um need to say publicly is
how much I
appreciate as um part of an organization
the reports that we are now getting on
in terms of what is happening in um
hydrocarbon events and um events with
our fers all those sorts of things that
are now coming through in terms of our
ability to communicate environmental
risk to AO I really appreciate the um
really good Communications that is
happening out of the infrastructure team
um to do with it and
um I know it's uh probably an extra
little bit of workload but it is much
valued because we're getting the
information really promptly we're able
to tell people if there is a hazard um
in terms of food Gathering and things
like that so um big props to all those
involved in that reporting and um I
understand from Erin that that is
actually going to help with the
um infrastructure reviews with um in
terms of storm water capacity and where
the weaknesses or strengths are in the
system for um
um our both our gray water and our black
water system so thank you very much
publicly saying that to the
infrastructure team saying that I'm moan
sometimes okay right we've got three
recommendations um received the report
note the ICC response to the State of
Emergency on September 21 and notes the
status update on the pipe renewals
program someone moved R seconded Grant
put that all those in
favor against that is carried thank you
Matt first time thanks Matt you
survived right that takes us to public
excluded
session uh can I have someone move
please we go to public exclusion I'll
use the excuses Darren used before the
reasons that remember
it's all those in favor I thank you
okay